this is an insane situation diplomatic
interpreters aren't necessarily on
everybody's radar one of the most
notable moments involving an interpreter
for what an American president was
saying was the fake sign language
interpreter at Nelson Mandela's memorial
pen Sanka Jean gee I don't know if you
remember that name due to some
combination of chance and I guess
security lapses during Nelson Mandela's
memorial service in South Africa a guy
was up next to Obama in doing sign
language interpretation and it was just
total nonsense okay let me remind you of
that Mandela address of a Charlotte and
the children and the grandchildren and
eventually we'll start to hear the
tribute we're here from the from the
from the family members we'll hear from
President Zuma President Obama a huge
cheer went up when the Chinese Vice
President came in I believe it's the
vice president he represented China and
let's not forget incredibly the Chinese
have invested so much in Africa South
Africa believe it I think likely taken
over it's not taken over us okay so if
you were watching with us you saw a sign
language interpreter there who was
communicating nothing with the signs
that he was using amazing story in and
of itself one of my favorite stories but
we have an even better story involving
interpreters and none other than our
fearless leader Donald Trump as you can
imagine when Trump meets with diplomats
and world leaders who don't speak
English there's an interpreter a
Japanese interpreter named Chikako
Tsuruta has said that he is and his
interpreter friends simply don't
translate Donald Trump verbatim because
they're worried it would make them as
interpreters sound stupid Shinzo Abe a
or whoever they're interpreting for in
the moment from Japan they believe would
look at them like they're idiots rather
than looking at Trump like the idiot
that he is if they were to translate
verbatim and this is causing huge uproar
within the interpreter community because
it's not seen as proper pad for an
interpreter to it all modify what the
principal is saying simply for fear of
coming off as intelligent the idea being
you're there is an interpreter to
interpret the words as they
are they might be violent they might be
horrible they might be evil sad funny or
in Trump's cases just indicative of
ignorance this is what we call a unique
problem of the trump era well part of
this is because there are so many Trump
isms that you couldn't possibly
translate that big league for example
but then I mean just this week you said
you know what uranium is right it's this
thing called nuclear weapons and other
things right no one's going to sign
their name off a translation of that
what somebody needs to tell them is
don't worry it's just a stupid sounding
in English when Trump says it you don't
have to worry about the translation
making it sound that dumb what's clear
is that when political shows end up
talking about diplomatic interpreters
for one reason or another it's usually
endlessly funny and that is of course
what is going on here with a imagine
having that job just just imagine being
in that position right now discuss this
or any other stories from today's
program on our reddit discussion forum
at david pakman.com slash read it that
is spelled re d di t today's episode of
a David Pakman show is made possible in
part by Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby
Parker recently did the right thing and
ditched advertising on right-wing
conspiracy website Breitbart pulling
their ads off and you can get the free
five-day home Tryon from Warby Parker
check out their glasses I use them when
I'm not wearing contact lenses I started
with the free at-home trial they send
you five pairs of glasses you see which
ones you like you send them back and
whichever one you pick they will put
your prescription into I like this
because I can actually show the glasses
to other people and not have to just
decide on the spot like in an eyeglass
store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS